so this this picture right over here
we've taken this square and we've
divided it into a hundred equal smaller
squares and then we've colored in let's
see how many we've colored in each of
these rows has ten squares so this is 10
20 30 40 41 42 43 44 45 46 47 so over
here we have colored in 47 out of the
hundred equal smaller squares or you
could say that this what's shaded in in
blue in green right over here this
represents 47 hundredths this is
represents 47 hundredths of the entire
of the entire hole now what I'm curious
about is I want to break up this
fraction I want to write it as 40 over
actually let me write it this way I want
to write it as 4 over 10 plus plus
something over 100 and I'll just write
star plus star over 100 and my question
to you is what is the star going to be
equal to the star is equal to what and
pause the video to try to figure it out
all right so let's let's work this let's
work this together so one thing that we
could say immediately is we could say
that 47 over 100 is equal to 40
hundredths 40 hundredths you see that
over here 10 20 30 40 hundreds this is
10 20 30 40 hundredths plus one two
three four five six seven hundredths
plus seven hundredths now 40 hundredths
is the same thing as four tenths 40
hundredths is the same thing as four
tenths there's a bunch of ways we could
think about it one is you could think
about dividing this larger larger square
into tenths so this would be 1/10 right
over here that would be 1/10 this would
be another tenth that's two tenths this
would be three tenths now all I'm doing
here is I'm dividing the larger thing
into 10 into tenths I should say if I'm
taking the larger if I'm taking the
larger square instead of dividing it
into hundreds I divided it into tenths
so this would be four tenths so let me
just do them 5/10 6/10 6/10 7/10 8/10
and 9/10 and then 10 tenths notice if
you look at the orange lines I've
divided my square not into 100 equal
sections but into 10 equal sections and
so you see these 40 hundredths that are
in blue right over there that's the same
thing as 1/10 2/10 3/10 and 4/10 so that
is the 4/10 right over there another way
you can think about it when you go from
hundreds to tenths each ten hundredths
each ten hundredths is are equal to 1/10
so you're dividing both the denominator
by 10 when you go from hundredths to
tenths and you would also divide the
numerator by 10 going from hundredths to
tenths so 40 divided by 10 is 4 100
divided by 10 is 10 so hopefully you're
convinced that 40 hundredths is the same
thing as 4 tenths but what's left over
well we still have the 700s over here so
40 hundredths plus 7 hundredths is the
same thing as 4 tenths plus 7 hundredths
so the star right over here this is
going to let me actually let me erase
this the star right over here I could
write that as 7 hundredths you see 47
hundredths which is all the stuff shaded
in that's the same thing is the 4 tenths
which is the same thing as 40 hundredths
shaded in blue plus these 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
hundredths right over here
47 100 or 47 hundredths 4/10 plus 7
hundredths